Hello world,
it's the Raj and blockchains are so 2017 2018 is going to be the year of block
daggers directed a cyclic graphs.
You might be thinking,
what did you just say?
And that's okay because I'm going to explain what I just said.
This video is about a crypto system called iota.
Okay?
So it's called iota and it uses a distributed ledger similar to bitcoin's
blockchain except it solves a lot of the issues or aims to solve a lot of its
issues and it's getting really popular and it's about number seven or number
eight on the coin market cap website.
And it's getting really popular and I've gotten a lot of requests for this
video.
So I'm going to do a video on this.
I've been studying it all day and yesterday,
so,
and I'm,
and I'm pretty excited about what I've,
what I've studied so far.
So I'm going to share with you what I've learned about this system today.
Okay?
So before we go into why I is awesome,
I want to start off with the problem with blockchains because blockchains are
awesome.
However,
they've got their problems.
99 of them,
but uh,
no,
not 99 problems.
Just some problems.
Okay.
I just wanted to slip that in there.
Okay,
so here we go with the problems.
The first problem with blockchains are scalability issues,
right?
There are endless debates on Twitter,
on slack,
on Bitcoin,
forums on scalability,
and there's 1,000,001 solutions to scalability,
right?
So bitcoin's blockchain takes about 10 minutes to confirm a transaction.
That's a long time,
right?
10 minutes to confirm a transaction is a very long time per system.
That's meant for micro payments,
right?
Micropayments from machines,
the machine to machine transfer.
We want machines to be transferring millions of transactions per second.
Ideally just giant Mesh networks.
A machine just transmitting value faster than any human could,
but for 10 minutes,
that's way too long,
right?
And that's what it's become.
There are currently 200,000 unconfirmed transactions on the Bitcoin blockchain.
So if we open this list,
this real time list of transactions,
okay,
this is real time.
We'll see that there are about 183,000 unconfirmed transactions and they're just
flowing in right now.
Just like that.
That's a lot of unconfirmed transactions and at 10 minutes per transaction,
that's just way too long.
Okay,
so that's a lot of unconfirmed transactions because it's taking so long to
confirm them.
And this is annoying,
right?
Why would you want to wait or pay a higher fee for a faster transaction
validation or deal with transaction uncertainty?
Let's say you're a multinational corporation like IBM or you know,
Chase Bank and you want to use blockchain technology to sync up your different
branches across the world.
You know,
use it to ledger,
to sync up the data and in a,
in a permissionless trustless way.
But if you're having to wait 10 minutes per transaction,
that's way too long.
So check this out.
These,
uh,
has 2000 transactions per second.
The Isa is the network globally.
It is the network for transmitting value.
Currently bitcoin is nothing compared to visa.
Okay?
Look at that.
Five to seven transactions a second.
That is nothing.
We way more than that.
So in,
in,
in comparison,
paypal is way more.
So how are we going to get up to that cell level?
You know what I'm saying?
How do we get up to that Vesa level?
And there's been so many different suggestions.
There's segway,
there's a lightening network,
there's all these solutions.
So I'm going to go into those a bit.
But that's the first issue with blockchain's scalability.
It's hard to scale a blockchain,
right?
You've got massive amounts of computing power.
You've got the speed of transactions decreases as a network increases in size,
and you don't want to store data on the blockchain,
right?
There's this,
there's this thing called blockchain bloat,
where you don't want to store data directly on a blockchain.
You want to have a pointer to data that's living somewhere like in a distributed
hash table,
right?
So scalability is one.
There's number two,
our fees,
right?
So the main transaction fee,
that is the average transaction fee for a transaction in the bitcoin network is
a dollar.
That might not seem like a lot of money,
but that's a lot of money for networks meant for micropayments,
right?
That's,
that's the whole point.
Visa has that 2% what is it 2% charge for?
For each transaction?
The coin was all about,
okay,
we don't need that anymore,
right?
We have,
we have,
uh,
feel as transactions or the very minimal fee.
Well now it's a dollar.
So anything under that is worthless,
right?
Because the fee is going to be greater than the transaction amount.
So micro payments under a dollar are virtually useless or impossible.
Now,
and this can be more than the transaction amount itself,
right?
So solutions include increasing the block size,
using lightening network,
central servers for off chain transactions,
like using Coinbase for example,
side chains,
tree chains.
There's a lot of proposals and there's a lot of ways that the core developers
and just the,
the bitcoin community is doing to fix that.
I'm not saying that they are not trying to fix it.
They are,
but it's still,
it's still,
um,
it's not fixed right there.
There are still,
the fee still exists.
So if we look at the fee over time,
it just going straight up.
It just exponentially over time for transmitting even 0.01 BTC,
which is what this graph is.
So
there's a lot of computing power required to maintain the bitcoin blockchain as
well.
As you probably know and mining has become somewhat centralized by these giant
mining pools,
right?
In China mostly.
But that's,
that's a lot like check and take a look at this chart right here of the
distribution of bitcoin mining power,
right?
If you look at g Hash and BTC guild,
together they make up 55% of the network to pools make up the majority of the
networks mining power.
Now that is centralization.
Okay?
That is a lot of centralization for supposedly decentralized network and
transaction speed declines as a network increases in size as more transactions
compete for the limited per block spaces.
So it's going to take more and more computing power to mine the same amount of
big coin.
You've got to buy these six.
If you want to be a miner,
you got to put the money in.
Okay,
you got to buy some giant a six.
Ideally if you want to make some profit and then you know,
meet or your electricity costs,
et cetera.
But I mean just look at this.
This is the hash rate,
you know,
the cost it takes to mine a block just going straight up,
which means you need way more computing power to mind,
the same amount of bitcoin that you would otherwise.
Okay.
And lastly,
one more problem.
They're vulnerable to quantum attacks,
right?
So bitcoin and other proof of work based blockchains are susceptible to being
broken by a powerful quantum computer.
So here's why.
The proof of work algorithm,
and I talked about this in previous videos,
but the proof of work algorithm is trying to solve random mathematical problems,
right?
It takes a certain amount of time to solve these problems.
So for a minor to generate a suitable hash to generate a block,
they've got to check around two to the 68th nonces.
That means numbers only used once to find that suitable hash.
So a quantum computer would need the square root of n operations to solve a
problem that would normally need an operations on a classical computer.
That's,
uh,
that's,
that's just an order of a magnet or of an order of magnitude difference.
So a quantum computer would need,
if we calculated it out,
which I did it right here,
it's a quantum computer,
will be 17 billion times more efficient in bitcoin mining and then the classical
computer,
right?
So right.
So the network requires lots of computing power to maintain its security.
And if a,
if a bad actor gained control of more than 51% of nodes,
that means they have more than 51% of computing power than they would be able to
double spend.
That means change a transaction history and spend money that they don't actually
have.
And that would break the entire network.
And everything is based off of classical computing,
right?
The laws of classical computers.
However,
quantum computers could do this 17 billion times faster.
So with just one very powerful quantum computer,
an attacker could break the entire network and this is very dangerous.
And we don't have a quantum computer like that right now.
It's all theoretical,
but their advances being made in this space and it's,
it's going to happen.
So we need some sort of quantum attack resistance mechanism.
And I've got this little infographic here on how a quantum computer works.
Uh,
but the most basic Eli five,
uh,
explanation I can give right now is that a classical computer,
only computes ones and Zeros.
So are binary,
uh,
operators,
whereas a quantum computer uses instead of a bit a cubit,
which can be both a one a zero and a one and zero at the same time.
So it's a super position of two different bits.
And this allows for types of computation that would not be possible on a
classical computer.
I just have a great video on this and a part of my math of intelligence series,
it's called quantum computation.
So check that out.
Just search Saroj quantum computation.
Let's keep going here.
Okay.
So those are all the problems with the blockchain.
So let's talk about why I oda as a crypto system is different from a blockchain.
So the first big difference is the structure.
So like I said,
blockchains are,
so 2017 iota uses what's called a block Dag.
Okay.
A directed a cyclic graph.
I just want to talk about the directed [inaudible] graph for a second.
Okay,
so dogs are not new.
A Dag is just a hierarchy of nodes that are connected to each other where no
note is a descendant of itself.
That means there are no cycles.
That's the word.
A cyclical.
There are no cycles,
right?
So it's just a hierarchy of nodes that are connected to each other in one
direction.
So there are a million different ways that you could structure a dag,
but that's the basic idea.
No cycles in this graph.
You could think of a file system as a Dag,
right?
Because it's just a hierarchy of nodes,
right folder within a folder,
within a folder,
get the,
the,
the protocol that get hub uses,
that's a deck.
A IPFS is IPFS the interplanetary file system.
That's a Dag.
In fact,
you can even think of a blockchain as a Dag,
right?
Because a blockchain doesn't have cycles,
but it's,
it's a very specific type of deck and that it's a single he linked to list.
It's a glorified singly linked list that is a,
that is secured by the proof of work algorithm.
A Dag is more general like,
so here's,
here's an image right here.
So blockchains are just blocks that are pointing to each other in one direction
and tangle,
which is what they call,
which is what iota calls.
It's a,
it's another word for it's deck.
I'm just going to call my dad guys,
I know you,
I know the iota guys are watching this right now.
Let's just call it dag please.
Let's not add more terminologies to this just for adoption.
So blockchains are sequential change where blocks are added in regular
intervals,
right?
But,
uh,
I OTAs data structure,
the Dag is able to achieve high transaction throughput by parallel parallelizing
validation and no transaction fees occurs occur for any transaction.
As it grows,
more participants make transactions and the overall system becomes more secure
and faster with confirmation times slash transaction finality going down.
What that means is as more nodes are added to the network,
the network's transactions actually get approved faster.
And that's in direct contrast to the blockchain.
The more nodes there are,
the slower the transactions are approved,
right?
And the longer it takes for a transaction to be approved.
Whereas in the block dag that iota uses,
the more nodes there are,
the faster the transactions are approved,
which is a much more scalable architecture.
And you might be wondering why is this,
but I'll go into that in a second.
Okay,
so it's still a distributed database.
It's still a peer to peer network.
It's still relies on consensus and validation mechanism.
And so those things are all the same.
It's just the structure that is different.
And the type of consensus and validation mechanism that's different too.
Right?
And it scales,
like I said,
it scales as blockchain scale.
The usability goes down as Iotas Dag scales,
the usability goes up.
So here's the big difference here is the big difference.
Number two,
there are two big differences,
right?
So the first one is the structure.
The second one is consensus.
So there are no minors.
So people who want to be miners,
too bad,
you can't be minors.
That's okay.
This is a good thing for the network.
Here's why.
So in,
so blockchain consensus is achieved by requiring multiple parties to race
against each other in an attempt to add the next block to the blockchain and get
the block reward,
right?
So miners are competing to mine the next block,
the fastest using their computing power and whoever's first to do it gets to
mine it,
and then they get the reward.
But because of this consensus is decoupled from transaction generation,
you have this whole separate group of nodes in the bitcoin network that are
dedicated to mining,
right?
And then all the participants in the network that are not minors,
all they do is just generate transactions,
right?
I want to pay for this,
I want to receive this,
I want to receive this.
And because it's the coupled that leads to further centralization,
right?
Because the,
these mining pools can occur,
but in iota there's no decoupling the,
all the notes are minors in a way,
or they're not minors.
Here's how it works.
So in iota,
every participant in the network making a transaction also actively participates
in the consensus.
Here's how,
every time you make a transaction,
you reference to transactions directly and and in a way other transactions in
the sub dag indirectly just by referencing too.
So there are no blocks in the classical sense.
Instead as single transaction references to past transactions,
right?
So here's,
here's a,
here's the graph.
It bundles all transactions in a directed asynclitic graft.
It's self regulating consensus,
no longer decoupled to a set of minors and it's very scalable with a low
overhead proof of work to prevent spam.
So check this out.
The green blocks,
our transactions in which consensus was achieved.
The red blocks are transactions where we are still uncertain on there.
Full acceptance and the gray blocks are unconfirmed transactions.
Ideally we want all of these transactions to be green,
right?
So from right to left or left to right,
depending on how this works,
uh,
eventually all the nodes will be verified if the nodes pointing to a verify that
it is indeed a valid transaction
and there are no transaction fees because there are no minors.
You,
when you make a transaction,
you have to approve to other transactions and then you have to perform the proof
of work algorithm.
So in a way you get paid by not having to pay a fee.
Right?
So because you're computing this proof of work,
which is for civil resistance,
right?
Because you're competing that proof of work,
you get to make a transaction without there being a fee and that is your reward.
So there are no transaction fees,
which is awesome.
So instead of a smaller subset of the network being responsible for the overall
consensus,
I.
E.
The miners,
the entire network of active participants,
I either devices making the transactions are directly involved in the approval
of those transactions.
And so consensus in Iota is no longer decoupled from the transaction making
process.
It's an intrinsic part of it.
And that's what lets it scale without any transaction fees.
Oh,
and one more thing,
like I said before,
it's quantum,
it's quantum resistant.
It's not success susceptible to quantum attacks.
And why is this?
Well,
it uses an algorithm called a winter knits.
One time signature.
I can make an entire video on how winter knits one time signatures work.
I'm not going to do that because it would be too long.
But check out the link right here in this Jupiter notebook,
which is in the get hub by the way.
Okay,
so here's a little picture of it.
All right,
so,
so here,
okay,
so you might be confused by this process of making a transaction.
Let me clarify it.
So it's a three step process.
It's a three step process.
So the first step,
like,
so let's say I want to pay,
you know,
I'm a machine,
I want to pay this other machine or even I'm a human,
you know,
I want to pay this other human,
here's how it works.
The first step is a sign that transaction input with your private keys.
What that means is you've got a unique set of private keys that identify you as
a unique individual node in the network.
When you sign a transaction that you are hashing,
you're creating the hash of that transaction using your private,
unique,
uh,
25 character key,
which means a transaction will be both unique and linked to you.
So you sign it with your private key.
Then step two is tip selection,
right?
So tips are the,
what iota calls these unconfirmed transactions.
So it uses the Monte,
it uses the Markov chain Monte Carlo Algorithm to randomly select two tips.
These are unconfirmed transactions,
which will be referenced by your transaction.
And in the code,
these are called the branch transaction and the trunk transaction,
right?
So once you've signed your transaction,
you then point to,
to unconfirmed transactions that you're going to have to approve before your
transaction is generated and validated.
So that,
so that's,
that's what you're paying for this.
And step three is to perform the proof of work algorithm.
In order to have your transaction accepted by the network,
you need to do some proof of work similar to hash cash,
similar to Bitcoin,
right?
And this is for civil resistance,
It's all about the computing power,
right?
You don't want any of the nodes in the network to gain control of the network by
having the majority of the computing power.
And that's what proof of work prevents because everyone has to compute this,
you know,
random mathematical problem.
A node would have to have more computing power than the rest of the,
an attacker would have to have more computing power than the then half to
network in order to double spent.
So proof of work is for double spending.
Tip Selection is computed using demark off chain Monte Carlo process.
I also have a video on how this works.
It's a part of my reinforcement learning theories.
I can go into a whole video on that,
but it's called Monte Carlo prediction.
Just Google that.
But I'm in shorts.
This is a probabilistic algorithm that samples randomly using distributions.
So it's uh,
so,
so Markov chain Monte Carlo methods sample from a set of nodes randomly using a
distribution function.
Okay.
So once you've competed,
completed these three,
three steps,
your transaction will be broadcast to the network and someone else will come
along,
choose your transaction in the tip selection process and validated and just like
that your transaction is confirmed.
So that's why the network gets faster.
Transactions get faster as the network scales because the more people there are
in the network,
the faster your transaction will be validated because there are more people
available to confirm your transaction.
Right?
So that's why it's scales as,
as there are more people.
Okay.
So I do want to say one thing.
So there is this concept of the coordinator right now in iota.
And so the coordinator is uh,
is run by the Iota Foundation.
The people who made iota and the coordinator check point's valid transactions,
which are then validated by the entire network.
Um,
it cannot go rogue as this coordinator is being checked and validated by the
entire network.
But what this means is,
first of all,
it's very hard to bootstrap a blockchain,
right?
Because you need,
it's,
you need a certain amount of nodes there for the computing power to be greater
than what an attacker would have,
right.
In order to gain control of the network.
Because bitcoin is so big as a,
as an,
as a system,
the amount of computing power and a tech would need is way too big.
Right?
But when you're starting a blockchain that relies on the proof of work
mechanism,
you've got to have some kind of system in place to prevent a bad actor from
taking over some sort of civil resistance.
So the way the Io,
the iota foundation has sought to prevent this is by creating this coordinator
that is run by them.
So it's centralized.
Yes,
it's a centralized node that validates transactions temporarily.
They've been clear about this since the beginning,
which I like and uh,
yeah,
it's centralized.
That's a bad thing.
But it's,
it's a temporary thing.
And I think that,
I mean,
their goals and their,
their aims and their white paper,
it all seems to be pointing in a decentralized direction,
but it's a temporary mechanism to validate transactions at the start.
Uh,
but eventually they're not going to need it or want it and it's going to go
away.
So I just want to mention that.
Okay,
so use cases,
right?
So first is data integrity,
So there's this mechanism to send messages,
secure messages between different nodes in the IOD and network,
which allows for uh,
nodes to communicate data rights.
And because there is this distributed ledger that there is consensus on that is
permissionless and trustless you can be,
you can ensure that the data that is being passed between these notes is,
is valid and data integrity is super useful for any kind of hospital records or
you know,
any kind of secure records that we need to,
government law,
legal,
you know,
anything that needs a lot of security,
this would be great in a trustless,
permissionless systems,
supply chains,
right?
Importers and exporters,
shipping liners,
logistic companies,
right?
They're all over the world.
They're global and they need to sync up on data.
And you know,
what the,
what the status is of,
you know,
delivery and what the status is of this and this and this and this.
And that's a perfect use case for distributed ledgers like iota.
Right?
And I mean this,
this system was meant for the Internet of things,
right?
So,
and when it comes to the Internet of things,
we are,
we need ways to share a bandwidth computing power,
resources,
uh,
you know,
data,
all sorts of these things.
And that is what this would be good at.
Or any kind of grid as well.
Solar Grid,
micro grid services,
electrical grid,
just anyways to share resources that doesn't need a human in the loop.
Just automatic systems that are trustless permission list that coordinate a
scarce resources amongst groups of people.
This would be a great use case,
right?
So it's key features are infinite scalability,
uh,
no fee microtransactions and quantum resistance.
Three key features that would be awesome to have.
So I mean,
the network already has 100 million in transactions that have occurred without
fees.
Uh,
yes,
it's using a coordinator right now.
Eventually it doesn't need to or they don't want it to be there.
And,
uh,
I think it's pretty cool.
I mean the promise of no fee transactions and a network that scales really well
and gets better in terms of the speed of transactions over time.
That is a,
that is a promise that I like.
Okay.
And I want that to happen.
We should want that to happen.
I,
Yoda is a proof of concept.
I mean everything in this space is a proof of concept.
Bitcoin is even a proof of concept.
What,
what I mean by that is it is not production ready yet,
nor is bitcoin even.
But,
uh,
I like where this is going.
I mean these guys seem to have no their stuff like they worked on next,
which was this,
this first asset transferring a service that uses blockchains in 2010,
2011.
So they'd been in the space for awhile and uh,
you know,
their,
their pre mine was a modest,
I think something like 500 k a and all the coins are,
are,
are generated,
all of them that can be created,
have been created.
So it's,
um,
I think it's a cool system and I,
and I want to see more of it.
I want to see more development of it,
more interest,
more excitement because uh,
yeah,
we need no fee.
Uh,
we need no fee distributed ledger services.
Right?
That's how we're going to really get this internet of things,
of things that are communicating and prince meeting value at millions of
transactions per second faster than these orders of magnitude faster than visa
screw Vesa we just go million times a second.
Okay.
That's where we want to be.
And if we can just bypass all of these issues that are coming up as the,
as the bitcoin blockchain scales and use something like iota,
that would be awesome.
So I think that yes,
there are still some problems and they have a lot promises,
but if they can come through with them and I think that they can,
that would be awesome for everybody.
Okay.
So,
uh,
let's,
let's look at the code for a bit.
So they've got this guy client,
which is really cool.
If you want to,
just the easiest way to get started,
this would be it.
It's built in javascript.
You can use NPM to install it.
It's based off of the electron wallet and instructions are here in this get hub
repository.
One more thing is that the client library in Python,
so the base library is in Java,
but they've got client libraries and Python and Java script,
uh,
and,
and c I think c as well,
but it's all on there.
Get Hub right here at Iota Ledger,
which you can look at right here at Java.
They've got the command line Hap,
they've got an android wallet.
Um,
yeah,
they've got,
they've got a lot of repositories here to play with in some different languages.
But what I'm gonna do is I'm going to just download this and just run it just
just cause,
so let me download that and I'm going to open in terminal.
Let's see.
Let me go right into that folder.
Okay.
Okay,
so pip install Pi Yoda.
Okay.
There we go.
Uh,
right pseudo pick three installed.
Pieta.
Okay.
All right.
So I've got iota up and running.
I have a full node running on my computer and using,
once I have this node running,
I've downloaded the Java client and then I can use any of the,
the python or the javascript Cli libraries to then integrate this into a web app
or a mobile app or whatever kind of APP I want.
But it's a pretty lightweight a client and it's easy to integrate into a web APP
or mobile APP.
So you can use it for,
you know,
having an online wallet or whatever payment system or where any kind of a system
you want to create.
The last thing is how to buy iota.
So found this great tutorial on bitfinex.com which is this website is,
it's an online exchange on how you can buy iota with bitcoin.
So it's a five step process.
But first,
first episode,
make sure your phones are on the exchange wallet.
So they have three dedicated wallets that you could use and you can instantly
move your funds from one wallet to another on the wallets page,
which is right here.
And so you can go to the trading page and choose the pair you want to trade.
And then there's an order form and they exchange tab.
You can click exchange of buy and then the order is going to appear if he,
so you've got to have bitcoin in order to buy iota coin.
And if you want to buy bitcoin than I would suggest using Coinbase,
uh,
as,
the most reliable way to buy them a it required.
You can do this from virtually any country,
I think at this point.
But,
uh,
you link up your credit card or debit card or bank account by Bitcoin and then
just transfer that bitcoin into a wallet.
And then from that wallet by Iota on Bitfinex or,
uh,
there's a couple of exchanges actually,
but I think bitfinex is,
is the one to do.
Please subscribe for more programming videos.
And for now I think I'm going to go buy some iota.
So thanks for watching.